the people defining what was called a
standard generalized markup language
sgml they took over the pointy bracket
notation and actually used it within
documents themselves it leads back into
computer science principles in so many
many ways and there has been so much
confusion so suppose you could say what
this episode is about is sgml HTML XML
what's the difference
or are they all the same no they're not
all the same way back in the late 1970s
early 1980s a team at IBM led by a man
called Charles Goldfarb who's trained as
a lawyer came up with the idea that it
would be really useful to be able to put
tags into documents to say what the
component parts of the document were
like P for paragraph which of course is
now so familiar to us from HTML as
pudding to bracket be closed pointer
bracket and they came up with this whole
notation for tags that's what it comes
down to it was a tag set notation people
could see the advantage of this
particularly if you had a huge
collection of documents that were just
crying out to be structured and there
are quite a few of those it could be
marriage records
it could be specifications of stuff
owned by the Department of Defense and
indeed some of the earliest users of
this tag set technology of sgml was the
Department of Defense and a thing called
a text encoding initiative and they were
just going to tag up everything in the
world that they could see with a
suitable tag set to make it easier to
access and to locate what you wanted if
it was in the big database so that was
the overall idea of it but in order to
show you how this sgml worked let's
start straightaway with something very
simple here is a sample memo there is a
2-part it's been sent to tony blair this
is way back in the
early years of this century round about
the time of the Iraq war I think is this
fictitious memo it is from the White
House the message is as follows and it
says the president says thanks for your
support
simple as that so those are two from and
a body a message body now as computer
scientists we realize straight away that
even if it's just a sequence you can
still present it as a left-to-right
structure within a tree so here's a
structured tree representation of what
we've just informally written down the
whole thing look at the top is a memo
and when you look below in the tree it
says are obviously a memo is a sequence
of a 2-part followed by a from part
followed by a body part right within the
to part that's just some text he says
Tony Blair from Part more texts from the
White House body part I've deliberately
made this a little bit more complicated
I've said that the body part can be a
few light just be a single paragraph a P
and within the P there could be
arbitrary mixtures of plain text
the president says or marked quotations
because what I'm going to do is to say
that thing that was in quotes is an
example of a quotation so that if in
future
Sean were to say to me go through all
our memos and dig out the bits that are
quotations or quoted speech then because
it's Tanglin marked it's so much easier
to pick out of course from that tree
then how does that translate into sgml
notation don't panic it's very very
similar to what you're now familiar with
us xml notation right here is a tag that
says this whole thing is a memo and this
is where it begins a to tag is to tony
blair but being a good boy I must
remember to end the to tag from the
White House end of the front part here
comes the body now I typeset the thing
previously as the word message but this
is just to illustrate that if you're
crawling all over this spec with a
engine you could take the decision that
every time I see the word body as a tag
I actually put out the typeset thing
saying message I could have said body
but the tags themselves can trigger
typesetting and stylistic decisions if
that's what you want to do so here we
come then here's the body of the memo
and like I said it's got to be a
paragraph denote with the P here's the
free text that I'm allowed
the president says and here is the
nested quote inside the paragraph
denoted with a q' tag thank you for your
support
end of quote end of paragraph end of
memo now some of you eagle-eyed will
immediately be dashing to the comments
on this video right now hold on and
we'll say you've missed out the end of
body tag to which the answer is yes sgml
allowed you to do that so long as you
warned it in the spec that goes behind
this of the legal tags if you said I
will optionally make end of body be a
miserable then the biblical handbook
here says you may specify that you want
certain end tags to be omitted provided
that doing so will not lead to ambiguity
and therein lies a complete nest of
vipers but in this particular case it's
alright you could put in and replace end
of body why did they do this well in
Charles gelfand area you have got to
remember disk space was massively
expensive and this sounds stupid but it
isn't every single saved end tag all
added up to so many hundred kilobytes
that you didn't need because it could be
assumed and safely replaced you hope so
you know they were not off their heads
they were trying to save disk space
here's where we have to try and choose
our words very carefully and say what
you're allowed to say and what you're
not allowed to say
in terms of building memo out of sgml
technology so let me begin with the
bedrock and when I say sgml technology
don't forget what I mean it's basically
sgml is like specifying the punctuation
if you think about it it's saying you
can have any tag you like but the
punctuation around it is pointy brackets
so here's our bedrock on top of this
using HTML notation I've devised a memo
language so remember the right way to
say this is that memo is an application
of sgml in other words it uses the
technology of you must not say memo is a
subset of sgml because they're different
things as Jim has a meta notation memo
is a specific tag set and just to tell
you I wasn't alone way before me in the
1980s there was a initiative within the
US Department of Defense and I think it
was to do with requisition and stores
and stuff like this I've even forgot
what the acronym refers to now called
towels one of the earliest applications
very big of sgml they thought was great
you know to tack things with what they
are what they mean there was also a more
scholarly initiative called the text
encoding initiative I mean one can
imagine there's no end of literature is
this an example of the early medieval
subjunctive you tagged it up to say yes
it is everything is hunky-dory document
professional thought this is wonderful
when computer scientist shouted at them
basically saying you shouldn't have
allowed MIT ihnen tags you know idea the
grief you will get into the answer I
think to that is if you're careful and
if you take advice you can avoid the
grief but in a closed world of document
professionals where very few people see
the mark-up this is all right then in
the early 1990s oh boy did something
happen that really blew it all wide open
and led to a much wider
adoption of sgml a certain Tim
berners-lee came along in the early
1990s about 1992 when it was first
revealed to an unsuspecting world and
Tim said I like this sgml and for these
web pages run invent my own tagging meta
notation I'll use the pointer bracket
notation of sgml but it was massively
massively successful it has great pointy
bracket notation we love this specify
our pages get them all out there
well the weaknesses in HTML first of all
because it didn't have a document type
definition to say what was optionally
immiscible or what wasn't Tim had a
certain view about well for example end
of Perak even nowadays in an XML
compliant browser it's not gonna refuse
to show your page because you go from P
to another P without formally closing
off the first Paradiso so if it's
another P I'm already in the middle of
the P I think a bit of closed off the
one I'm doing go into another one fine
but there were far worse problems than
that and they really really came home to
roost within the first 18 months in 1994
there was a meeting I was there at
Edinburgh where all of this came out
into the open a full furious frank
discussion took place about what was
wrong with HTML could we ever put it
right this has to be another story
they wanted it be clear it's part of the
definition and they said easy we're not
going to call it hell or do a very quick
report on how to do a subset of full
sgml that's cleaner which insists